Two or three days ago, I got a letter from
one of our fans and it’s different from
any other letter that we have ever had, because
this fan, Young, has attached to it a sample
of an element and what’s more it is an element
that I had never seen.
It’s scandium. It’s only a small piece
but according to my colleague Steve, it’s
a very expensive element, so this might be
quite valuable, and scandium is a really interesting
element, much more interesting than I realised,
when I first talked about it on the video.
Scandium is an element which chemists usually
ignore, I have never used scandium in any
of my research.
It was one of the elements that Mendeleev
predicted ought to exist when he first devised
the periodic table, when he made it there
were lots of elements which were not known,
but what he did was to predict that there
were holes in various places where he felt
that there ought to be an element and because
obviously these elements did not have names,
he called them Ekea boron or Ekea aluminium
or Ekea silicon meaning underneath those elements.
And the triumph of the periodic table was
that people actually discovered these elements.
And the first one that was discovered was
the element Gallium (Ekea Aluminium) and the
second one was Ekea Boron which is scandium.
Now you might think that it is a bit surprising
because if you look at a modern periodic table,
scandium and boron are really quite a long
way apart but in the original way that Medeleev
started the periodic table when he wrote it
down first, scandium and boron came very close
together because both of them, have three
electrons in their outer shell which makes
their chemistry quite similar. Of course Medeleev
did not know about electrons, but he guessed
from looking at titanium which has four electrons
and calcium which has two that he thought
there was something missing and what is also
interesting about these three elements that
he predicted is that they all ended up with
names of countries. There was gallium that
was named after France, from the latin word
for France. Scandium that was named after,
well perhaps not a country but a region, Scandinavia,
and then germanium, that was named after Germany.
The first time that an element was discovered,
when gallium was discovered, people said well
it was just luck, but when scandium was discovered,
they really began to take Mendeleev pretty
seriously, and by the time germanium was discovered
they really all decided that Mendeleev was
right. Scandium, because it is an uncommon
element, is one where people don’t know
much about the chemistry. I have never really
done any research in this area but like many
elements suddenly there comes a time where
they become really quite popular and topical
and now is the time for scandium and the reason
is that scandium is a really light metal.
Its density is slightly less than 4, that’s
4 grams per cubic centimetre and that is very
much lighter than most metals. Copper is nearly
10 and lead and gold are close to 20, so this
is really very light. So why should metals
be important if they are light, and that’s,
the reason is sometimes you want to use a
metal, but you don’t want the object you
make to be very heavy and so for example titanium
which is very light, is used for making everything
from golf clubs to jet fighter planes, where
you want it to be really light either so that
you can swing it fast or fly fast. For scandium
the reasons are rather different, people are
now thinking about using hydrogen, to power
cars, to use hydrogen gas, to use hydrogen
gas as the fuel to power cars, but what they
want to do is to store the hydrogen, in the
equivalent of the petrol tank. You can’t
just pressurise the hydrogen as in a gas cylinder
because the container would be so heavy, that
your car would be like a military tank it
would be so heavy. So what they want to try
and do is produce a chemical compound, which
is a bit like a sponge that will absorb the
hydrogen and then for example if you warm
it gently they hydrogen will come out, and
it is here that you want the metal to be light
because you want this material that you are
using to store hydrogen not to weigh very
much. Because you have got to cart it around
in your car all the time, and scandium compounds
are now looking really quite promising, for
storage of hydrogen, and the idea is that
rather like a molecular model kit, where you
have balls joined with sticks, you can use
organic compounds, those of carbon and hydrogen
with a little oxygen, like sticks to join
together scandium atoms, and produce a structure
which has a lot of holes in it and then the
hydrogen can go into those holes and be stored
without needing an enormous pressure.
Sounds like an incredibly complicated way
to make a fuel tank.
It is quite complicated but on the other hand,
if it works, you don’t need to understand
the chemistry. You just add the hydrogen to
your tank and away you go.
How can you have got to your ripe old age
as a chemist and never seen scandium?
Well, chemists very often use compounds, salts
of metals, but it’s not too often that you
use the metal itself and salts because they
don’t have to be purified and so on quite
as much as the metals are easier to get, they
are not as expensive and so there are lots
of the elements which I haven’t seen, but
I am really quite pleased with this sample
of scandium, so when I am finished I am going
to frame it and hang it on my wall.
So we have one of my students who works with
one of my colleagues, Martin Schroder and
the student, has done his whole project, three
year project, on the chemistry of scandium,
so when I got this letter I asked him: Have
you ever seen scandium? And he hadn’t, he
had never seen the metal, so he was really
quite excited to see John’s letter.